[Music]
so we're going to walmart
and we're going to go on a little
shopping spree whatever you guys want
clothes shoes
furniture dog food food anything you
guys want
[Music]
okay
betty you're saying you wanted what
i want a microwave microwave we'll get
you a microwave oven
that'd be nice to have
timmy what would you like to get
would you like to get jimmy
we'll figure it out
we'll figure it out when we get there
lorraine you like going to walmart
mama
lorraine
do you like going to walmart
yeah yeah yeah
so you explained to me
last time we spoke betty that you
actually understand everything that ray
timmy and lorraine
are saying i can understand them
a lot some people
some people understand too what they
talk about yeah i think i think they're
more intelligent than people think
they just have a difficult time
communicating yeah
yeah but you understand and that helps
right did they go to church yeah people
cannot understand and pretty good they
say
and
well they don't
we're teaming them don't go to church
and they're missing them
are you guys going to church now because
of the coving thing came in the lighting
yeah there you go
i did ray you don't go to church
great people they took down one day
and people think
a woman was like a bunny okay now if ray
and i would watch football on sunday
morning you guys could have gone
so i don't go to church no more yeah man
it's such a beautiful street you guys
live on
it's really beautiful in this part of
the country all my life
though
six years old you lived here
what were your favorite years of your
life favorite time
what was your favorite time favorite
memory you have of your childhood
not much
mommy was tricky on this girl
she wouldn't let her get out of here
very
hey
protective
[Music]
right you haven't you ever driven a car
is ready over driven
maybe i'll take take you for a little
driving lesson right
you never know
hey
how about you timmy you ever driven a
car no junior movie yeah yeah
i drove a car a long time ago that quick
when i got nervous yeah
yeah
so i just quit driving so betty you
never had children no no kids of your
own you were just taking care of the
family yeah you've been doing that your
whole life
well i took your about 12 years ago
you took care of what i took your kids
at the doctor baby or no i'll go to
school
and come home and can't fall asleep
i don't remember i was sitting down
because my mommy wouldn't
you know my mommy would never cook
so your mom couldn't cook mom could cook
with people you know she was like they
know
your mom couldn't stand up
what was wrong
she had
well your mom with cancer my momma got
cancer
and heart travel
[Music]
who's the oldest of the kids
mom's you traveling she fights away
right
what did timmy say
is that you guys are what oh i see and
who's the youngest
timmy
jimmy the youngest one timmy how old are
you
he's how are you
you never had boyfriends nothing like
that i just had boyfriends when i did
school yeah
yeah
but you never got married
[Music]
it's nice that they paved your road
your road used to be a dirt road
when i first met you
so they paved it how long ago do they
pave it but 10 years ago
[Music]
10 years ago
they just come down past the roads and
through all that
[Music]
so the rest of your siblings the ones
that are still living
are where uh
the the other brothers and sisters
[Music]
i'm sorry not siblings brothers and
sisters where where are they living well
one of my sister lived at a hall down
below us down there not too far
past the church go to church house
and then i got a brother luther here in
bagley and then i got a brother living
soapy bubble
[Music]
and they're married or single still
one of my brother's murray and she
assisted murray we lived in a hall
and i lost one of my sisters
[Music]
and she when she was married and
her husband died
and then her josephine
in the bed
[Music]
[Music]
there's four dollars to me so
going to pull up to a toll here do you
know how to pay a toll to me i could tow
right there when they stop
y'all getting my bun
number
no when you go to the toll booth we're
coming to the toll right now
you wanna roll down timmy's window here
we go
[Music]
good job timmy yeah
[Music]
so
[Music]
you been to walmart before ray
he's never been mm-hmm
his first time actually that's his first
time oh wow
i don't mean i think we shop at
baltimore
all right
yeah
yeah okay well this will be your first
you get whatever you want
and then i'll stop at the dollar store i
mean
the dollar store got your jeans to get
my dog food
and stuff
dog food
you know you know where one more
are you excited timmy
is really having a hard time walking
hurting oh your knee is hurting ray
i guess right
sorry when i got some cream
ah
why that team
all right whatever you want
get whatever you want
um
[Music]
there you go
you guys like potato chips
you guys like potato chips
[Music]
take it
oh guys
[Music]
you want a watermelon
can you grab it
grab a melon
basket
yeah
ray's knee is hurting
knee hurts
oh goodness
too
honey
you want to get some clothes
yeah
ray pick up pick up some clothes
i know you need pants and a belt
this will get your belt
come on ray
pick out a belt
all right make sure it's a good size
make sure it fits
excellent hey
hey hi
hi here where's the belt
you want to steal it
perfect
perfect good job
now i see betty how you have to do all
the work nobody's helping you
no one helps you you're you're pushing
and pulling carts
oh it's nice
is it the right size
what size is it
hold them up
i think this is women's clothing right
ray
that's ladies
he's shopping for women's
clothes what is it lauren
what is that
timmy you like shopping
you guys are so cute
new shoes
strong
where's your candy
get your tummy
um
[Applause]
[Music]
come on
hey how're y'all doing
hey
hey
hey it's kenneth
it's
yeah this is your this is your brother
kenneth right
can you just happen to be here
yeah what a coincidence
how can they get me the phone you came
here for a phone well your family's here
your whole gang is here yeah they're all
scattered but here they are
timmy and uh lauren
so you're you're you're one of the
siblings
you're you're you're kenneth
you're one of the younger ones
no i got something a little bit older
right
hey
how old are you i was 64. you're 64.
they're about the same as you though
yeah yeah yeah
so who who were your parents your
parents were gracie
john gracie and john
which is the same as ray
same as betty too yeah
yeah yeah your brothers and sisters
where are the rest of your siblings
rest your brothers and sisters
yeah timmy's
timmy's nephew
and you you live down how far away do
you live from babel or you live in
beaver yeah i'm moving across the
highway yup
it's so funny that we met here at
walmart
you mean my hurry
that much dead dog
[Music]
and you grew up uh
well i grew up i had waiting hard a
little bit yeah why not not growing up
yeah no i i met you the very first time
i came the other day
josephine
yeah so so you you're married
i was married by night now oh i see okay
excellent how often do you see the rest
of the gang i know how are you seeing
them i don't even hardly get up there no
no
well it's great to see you guys yeah all
together
all right kenneth all right have a great
weekend
[Music]
cj you guys know each other say guys
how do you know how do you know right in
the game
we got there right right
yeah i used to live right up the road
from oh you're a neighbor
they're still there
no i live in sofia
yeah but they're still in the same house
yeah are they
how y'all been doing
all right
yeah i heard about
freddie a while back uh
i believe it was peanut telling me about
it
that he passed
away you're being have yourself okay
yeah
he got awful right
in his knee oh it hurts
yeah that all right
she taking care of you
well ray ray it's good to see y'all
again okay
let's go up here and pay for this and
get out of here
it's nice to meet you nice to meet you
you run into everybody here at walmart
okay
me
hey
in here
[Music]
hey
hey
hey you gotta pay for it right
he wants his belt
hey
yeah men's room is on the left
not the ladies room
sorry about that
[Music]
[Music]
great job you guys
yeah i'm tired yeah yeah i bet you're
tired it was a lot of shopping
you got kitchen stuff you got stuff for
your beds you got clothes you got food
all kinds of stuff
really do you enjoy that
i was asking if ray enjoyed it yeah
george
[Music]
there you go
ray
it's your turn
i don't know
no no no no you're getting
you're gonna pay the toll no
no hey good to here
[Music]
thank you thank you
good job right
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
ugh
wow
[Laughter]
timmy thank you thank you for all your
help today
thank you for all your help today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
ah
we're home
[Music]
oh
how are you ray
hey good to see you
what are you showing me
what's
we got you some new clothes you didn't
wear them
can you sit there sit right here right
sit right here right here
sit right here
this year
you lived in this house pretty much most
of your life right you lived in this
house most of your life what's the
craziest thing you've ever seen here
[Music]
timmy what are you doing
is that a crossword puzzle
[Music]
oh
come on ray
[Applause]
ryan
ray come on out here
come on ray
let me try
hi
[Music]
ray your knees hurting
is it just
your knees are written old
come on come on outside just for a bit
just for a quick little video
come on everybody wants to see you
[Music]
oh it'll help you forget about your pain
there we go
come on
come on come on come on
there we go
here comes ray
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so this is this is larry who's another
you're the brother of betty and ray and
lorraine and everybody
you you chose not to be in that first
video because
for whatever reason but
you and betty kind of hold this house
together yeah yeah
and you you you it wasn't for you i
don't know what these guys would be
doing right that's right
i'm here to take a cab
you and betty do a great job about jake
kevin brother and you lived here for how
long
oh i came back in two valentines 17
years 17 years
but betty's been here a long time yeah
yeah and this this is your daughter
also betty
hello hi betty
and there's ray with his aching knees
and his chew
hey guys
what happened to your pants i bought you
new pants
where's your new closet right
they're dirty
hippy
saying that you bought him um pants and
shirt yeah we got him a bunch of clothes
and what story did you guys say
walmart
so so betty you uh you got
like thirty thousand thirty one or two
thousand 000
through the gofundme
campaign that my viewers
donated to
you guys are thinking about maybe if the
neighbor decides to sell his house which
would be a much larger house than this
one that's one possibility right and if
that doesn't come through then because
the neighbors hasn't decided whether he
wants to sell or not
another possibility is fixing up this
house right
we would yes
would getting a trailer be a solution
huh would getting a trailer be a
solution for anything i ain't gonna
waste anything well you could put it
over here where uh
where jason had his place
right next door
just an idea
you'll figure it out
but would you like to say thank you to
the viewers for uh
helping you guys out
yeah
say thank you to everybody
say thank you to everybody thank you
everybody
there we go
that's all that's all it takes
timmy is your life a little better with
all the the money that everyone gave
yeah see timmy likes it
and lorraine how are you
all right
mark's talking to you
she's in a hard day no now yeah she's
she's she's in another world
[Music]
you have a nice pillow there buddy
how many how many dogs do you guys have
i've got four you have four dogs two big
ones that black one that display from
that black one and
nine very two small ones
and
one of them belonged to jason oh is that
one of them jason did belong to jason
yeah he's a daddy's dog now and jason is
in uh jail he's in jail right now he's
killing jail don't they talk about
getting my priests about a win
jason's uh a relative not not a
he's a guy where's jason he's a cousin
nephew okay
and if you're the better cousin of me
yeah i see and you are larry's daughter
yep yep
all right you guys thank you for uh
letting me stop by
again the walmart trip was uh was
helpful right
yeah i see your microwave over there on
the table already yeah she's been using
it
good
good that's what that's where we gonna
tell me the other day she's like i've
been using my microwave we're just
trying to make your lives a little bit
easier a little bit better
all right you guys thank you thank you
very much for everything thank you
i hope you guys survived the winter i
don't know if i'll be back again in the
cold weather but we'll see
it's got to be tough right
let me go say goodbye to ray
gray is it your knee
[Music]
i hope you feel better
nothing's cheap anymore
okay ray thanks for letting me let me
come bye
oh
you